- [Interviewer] All right, so Debbie.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] We met many
years ago and I photographed you
and we just ran into
each other on the street.
So, tell me what's new since
the last time I photographed you
which is about seven,
eight, nine years ago?
- [Debbie] Well, I'm clean now.
- [Interviewer] You're
clean now which is great.
- [Debbie] I've been clean.
- [Interviewer] So, the drug
that you were using was what?
- It was called, crack cocaine.
- [Interviewer] Yes, I've heard of it.
So, how long have you been clean?
- Really, I couldn't even tell you.
It's been quite some time.
- [Interviewer] Years?
- A few years.
- [Interviewer] Is the
temptation still there
when you see it cause it's everywhere.
- No, but what it does, it bothers me
to see other people doing it.
If I can get clean, they can too.
It's not a problem.
What I can't stop doing
is smoking cigarettes.
Well, I can, but it's harder
to stop those than it is drugs.
- [Interviewer] What do you think keeps
all these people on the
street doing crack or heroin?
- I don't know.
Probably, like if they were in a program
like a rehab or whatever,
things that took them out,
like a family member
dying or stressing, yeah.
- [Interviewer] Stress.
I don't know, having to
do things that happened
when they were a kid, being traumatized,
things like that more than likely.
Or there's some people would just like it.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] I almost
think some people are
driven to self-destruct.
- Exactly.
- [Interviewer] And there's
nothing that's going
to get in the way of that.
- Nothing, they won't let anything.
- [Interviewer] They won't
let anything get in the way
of them self-destructing.
- Exactly.
- [Interviewer] That's
what I see a lot of.
- Exactly, exactly, some
of them don't realize
that's what they're doing.
They're self-destructing
and they don't realize
that's exactly what they're doing.
- [Interviewer] No, if you
were explaining it them
they'd think you're speaking French.
- Yeah, they would, yeah, they'd
think you're the crazy one.
Get away from me.
- [Interviewer] But, if
you see their behaviors,
you've lost your kids,
you've lost your family.
- I look at them and I'm like,
"Oh my God that used to be me."
And it makes me a little sick to myself.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] I think
once you've gotten clean
then you see the picture very clearly.
- Exactly and you see what you
used to be and it's horrible.
- [Interviewer] When
you're in the middle of it
you don't see anything.
- It's horrible, like you just said,
when you're in the middle of
it you don't see any of that.
You glamorize yourself.
You know what I'm saying?
You look good, you talk good,
you act good, you dress good.
All of that and really it's awful.
- [Interviewer] Seeing you
before and seeing you now,
you look healthier, your
energy is much better.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] You're more
coherent and clear thinking.
I can just remember all
of this like yesterday
and you've improved in every--
I almost didn't recognize you
when I saw you on the street.
- Really?
- [Interviewer] You just look
so much healthier and better.
- Well thank you.
I'm trying, I wanted to give
up but that would be giving up
on myself, be giving up on my family.
Everything, me giving up
on everything and I can't.
- [Interviewer] So, tell
me what got you into drugs
in the first place, years ago?
- My family, I hate to say
that, it sounds bad, I know.
I was traumatized as a child
from age four until I was 13.
- [Interviewer] By whom?
- A lot of different people.
I'd rather not get into it.
It's pretty bad.
Okay, I was molested, I beaten.
I was molested by my brother first.
He was the very first
one at four years old.
He penetrated my diaper, he
penetrated me with his thumb.
And that went on for a couple
of years and he dropped it off.
He didn't die or anything,
but he stopped doing it.
And I had five stepfathers
that took his place.
Separate ones, at different
times periodically.
My mother was a blackout
drunk, a happy drunk,
a violent drunk, whatever
kind of drunk there is,
she was it.
So, she never knew that
I was being molested
by my stepfathers.
Every one of them did
it and I had two sisters
but I was the only girl left at home.
So, because I'm the baby girl.
- [Interviewer] You're the youngest one.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So, this
went on for quite a while.
- Yeah, until I was 13.
- [Interviewer] And at 13 what happened?
- I left, I ran away cause
my mother had the audacity
to tell me if anything happened to you,
she knows damn well there did,
there was also two other men,
I don't even know their names,
it was back when I was a child.
If anything happened to
me I wanted it to happen.
I did it, I'm a whore.
- [Interviewer] According to her.
- According to her I'm a whore.
"Get out of my house."
And she literally kicked
me out of the house at 13.
Yeah, so I went ahead and left at 13
and I've been on my own ever since.
- [Interviewer] Where do you go at 13?
- All over, traveled, with this.
- [Interviewer] Where'd you grow up?
- Alabama.
- [Interviewer] Which city?
- Birmingham, in Jefferson County
and I grew up in Shelby County in Chelsea,
little town called Chelsea.
That's where I went to high school at
and everything to, it's
called Chelsea High School.
That's why I say high school,
but it's all elementary,
preschool, elementary and all that,
all in the one.
- [Interviewer] And
when did the drugs come
into the picture?
- When I was eight.
- [Interviewer] You were eight?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How'd you get
introduced to drugs at eight?
- God rest her soul, my sister, Victoria.
She was the first person to
ever put a pipe in my mouth
or a needle in my arm when I was 12.
And it released a lot
of the pain out of me.
However, I don't blame her anymore
because I'm the one they kept doing it.
I did that.
I'm not mad at her or nothing anymore.
However, this man named
Don, he's a counselor,
at the Hilton Treatment Facility,
which I graduated from.
Also, I'm an alumni from there.
He told me, no, I need to still blame her
because if it wasn't for her,
I would've never started.
He doesn't know that,
he doesn't know that.
I could have did it on my own.
- [Interviewer] I think taking
responsibility is the key.
- But, regardless I kept doing it.
I kept putting the pipe in my mouth.
I kept putting the needle in my arm.
I did that.
She was murdered at 23 and she was shot up
with enough cocaine
poisoning to kill two people
and that was back in Alabama.
Luckily I was here but it
still tore me up pretty bad
because I was really, really close to her.
Really close to her.
My father was murdered when I was three
and I watched that happen.
He was shot in the back of
the double barrel shotgun.
There was a hole in his
back as big as a baseball,
as he was breathing,
you could hear the gravel
going in and out of his back.
I was laying on top of him because
from the impact of the shot in his back,
you know the old cars,
they got the little push
button thing on the handle
and it opens, the old cars.
From the impact of the
shot, it caused his thumb,
I guess the reflex to open
the door where I was pounding
on the window, calling him
his name, daddy, daddy, daddy
and I fell out on top of him.
That's how I know the gravel
going in and out of his back,
how it sounded.
- [Interviewer] How much do
you think the environment
you grew up in played a
part in your addiction?
- All of it, for me all of it.
All of it.
Now, that I'm thinking...
I don't know how to put that.
I don't know how to put it.
- [Interviewer] You've
done it and sometimes words
are not going to--
- There's nothing I can
say, yeah you're right.
- [Interviewer] I think you already have.
The example that you
set is a beautiful one.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] I'm proud of you.
- Thank you very much.
- [Interviewer] You made my
day when I saw you walking out
towards my car.
(laughing)
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] I know her
but that does look like--
- That doesn't look like her.
- [Interviewer] She should
be worse not better.
- That part, I should be dead.
- [Interviewer] You look better.
So, the skin condition it
seems like it's improved
since last time.
- [Debbie] It has, when
he gets hotter though
and my body temperature
rises, I'll break out more.
It broke out on me at first when I was 14.
It's called Neurofibromatosis,
it's not drug related,
in the ball of nerves at
the bottom of my spine
there is a disorder in there
and the doctors were unable to locate it.
When I was younger I also
went to a dermatologist
and he said it was a
deficiency of vitamin A.
I was fed all sorts of
vitamin A, it didn't work.
Like I said, a few minutes
ago, it's not drug related.
It is a nerve disorder
in my ball of nerves
at the bottom of my spine.
- [Interviewer] And it's caused by stress
or something like that?
- [Debbie] Yes, it's caused
from being traumatized.
Like I was from age four, even until now
but I am doing so much better.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, it
looks much better yet.
- [Debbie] This is looking
better, I'm looking better,
I'm feeling better, I am better.
- [Interviewer] Yes, you are.
So, how many years were you using?
- I'm 50 years old,
I know I look 90 but whatever,
and I used for 42 of those years, man.
If I can do it, anybody can do it.
Anybody, I don't care who you are
or what you're doing, you can stop it.
You know, you can stop it.
Look at me.